hello everyone from Berlin from the
University of Berlin
um today I'll have the pleasure to talk
about probabilistic demand forecasting
at scale
um and yeah just before we dive in let's
go introduction and myself I'm hack up a
plot scientist working currently at
zalando and uh yeah so I've been
building ml products for the last five
years and working on forecasting topics
for the last two years
um I'm passionate about everything that
touches data science deep learning green
tea cycling and running
so yeah if you're also passionate about
any of these topics like you know feel
free to contact me either via Discord or
via LinkedIn or yeah let's just get in
touch
okay
so today's agenda is straightforward
we're gonna start by uh posing the
problem of the math forecasting and
e-commerce that I work in
um then we're gonna have a look at okay
like with what type of covariates we can
use for demand forecasting we're going
to have a review of deterministic
forecasting methods and their
limitations
um then we're gonna Embrace together
uncertainty with probabilistic modeling
and end up by presenting a real industry
workflow for training and serving
forecasting models that is inspired by
my team and my Department's work
all right so um the problem of the math
forecasting
um
the first thing that we need to say is
that um demand forecasting is a core
input to Logistics and planning right um
it is a core input for making decisions
um we can for one we have several areas
of indications one major application is
inventory optimization right where we're
interested in answering questions such
as what are my optimal inventory levels
for my different squs or products
um when I need to inbound to you know
constantly replenish my uh my stock
where to optimally allocate the
inventory in my you know a network of
warehouses or in my network of stores
the second application is also related
as capacity planning right all of these
stores warehouses
um work with real human beings right um
hence it's very important that we
optimally plan uh the workforce so that
they are able to process either the
outbound or the inbound
and the third one that we can encode is
assortment planning right so we are
we're interested in at any given time
try to have them like let's say the most
optimal assortment or products possible
online using the math workers okay so
this is just like um like an exhaustive
list of you know um
of potential applications but there are
many others that can follow up but these
are very very common and and these are
the topics that my team you know handle
on
so um yeah
one of the biggest problem not the only
one with one of the biggest problem in
demand forecasting is the problem of
sn22 right there are so many
unpredictable things that can impact
demand
um we can quote for example weather
right
um
today is snowing in Berlin I'm pretty
sure that you know um demand for jackets
increases suddenly
we can have customer tastes and
preferences that change over time
um we can have economical factors just
like we saw in 2022 where you know we
had all type of lows and highs
um pandemics again not that far ago
um only two years ago we had the the
industry being completely uh disrupted
where the man you know got the positive
boom but still you know we had uh let's
see an unpredictable factor and the
increase of demand and also this year
unfortunately uh more sad events such as
War
um we have you know we live in an
uncertain world and the only constant is
is changing and uncertainty it's a
constraint that we can't exclude or we
can you know um you know just eliminate
it's it's there and we have to work with
okay
so this is uh the context in which we're
gonna tackle right
um before diving into the modeling
problems I want to you know like to kind
of present uh the data that we can use
to to to to capture this uncertainty and
then go into the model right so what
type of covariants or features we can
use
um as I said you know time series
forecasting exercise the first natural
thing is to have a temporal and lagged
features such as um you know Auto
aggressive features let's say this is
demanded time T then you can take
demanded time minus t uh at time T minus
one T minus two T minus three etc etc
etc this is up to the manual how far you
need to go based on the on the on the
pattern of your data right and we can
have temporal indicators we can also
have specific dates and events being
encoded
um yeah we can have weather and economic
features data um example is absurd
feature observed weather since uh since
the start or the forecasted weather for
the future we can have micromatic
indicators
um especially like in this specific time
this is very useful we can have a look
at for example the consumer confidence
indents like the inflation of of prices
unemployment rate etc etc etc we can
also go into Google Trends where we
would try to catch uh let's say how
trendy the industry level uh keywords
are at at the moment how the competitors
are performing on the on the on the
clicks how Our Brands categories
interactions Etc or other uncertainty
factors right so such as reported covet
cases the main key Point here is that um
we have a lot of you know uh indicators
around the weather and economic feature
that do capture the environment in which
we're in right and ideally the
environment in which we want to have the
demand forecasted
okay
um the third level is SQ and posting
level features right let's say you are
interested in in like the lowest level
of fine grain possible which is the
article level so in this case you can
really go and take features such as the
price if you know what advance that
certain discounts are going to be
applied then you take the discounts
um you can take some SQ taxonomy
indicators such as Clauses jackets
winter jackets
um you can take X SQ you know
characteristics like the size of the
product the color the material
composition or you can even go a bit
more crazy and you only have creative
features such as normal embeddings you
can take the images of your product
um you can take the bottleneck features
from that images
um you can have the title or description
represented via encoded vectors etc etc
and so there are many ways many creative
ways to catch the optical representation
but also uh the environment in which you
are right
um this is fairly simple now that you
know we have the problem uh the
construct of uncertainty the data
um let's start with the first idea that
we can come up with which is uh using
deterministic forecasting methods and
we're going to discuss why you know
they're not fully ideal given what we
just described right
um okay so deterministic forecasting is
also called Point forecasting right
where we're mainly interested in in
forecasting one value at any given time
T in the future right so we only predict
with one value and this is most of the
time the average expected demand okay
um to train the model we use pointwise
loss functions such as MSE
and here the literature is pretty pretty
large or like like you know we have a
large set of models that you can apply
um like you can start with the classical
methods what we call like the
statistical methods such as arima
exponential smooshing
um um yeah or profit you can go into
more machine learning models extra boost
GBM or the ones that you know and very
recently where we have seen a big boom
in the research and also in the
application of them uh deep learning
models that that are are performing
pretty well on the specific case
um you you can have the choice to either
use covariance or not depending on on
the model
um and you can either do single shot or
or a recursive forecasting right um the
main point here is that deterministic
forecasting is is pretty used it's
pretty old it's it's pretty well used
um and you have you know like you have a
little uh that's a big literature in
terms of choices to do that
right
um but we wanted to discuss also about
the limitations right not only what it
is why this is not perfect right so um
let's play
um let's see let's play a game together
to demonstrate the point that you know
this is not yet fully ideal okay
let's say uh we are interested in uh in
uh in learning the demand for the
specific shoes okay like like let's say
yours Orlando like you have like you
know shoes that you want to replenish
and you need to know the demand for that
specification okay and I come and tell
you okay like the demand for the
specific shoes is is gonna be five
thousand units for uh next year all
right
um just have a look at that
then suddenly I actually present you two
different forecast distributions
possible around that mean value right I
actually tell you hey it is highly
likely that the distribution around this
average value that I provided you can
follow one of these two distributions
right it can be more like this it can be
more gaussian or even here a log right
logarithmic
um then
um
the question here to you is really think
about it is if I give you the
distribution around this mean average
would you consider this mean average in
the same way right would you take the
same risk would you buy 5 000
for the next week given that you can
have one of these three possibles
um just think about it
um yeah well if if you are you know
honest the answer is no right like we
don't have the same information okay
um if I give you this you can be sure
that you know like the like the like the
uncertainty around the distribution is
low here it's a bit higher and here we
can have you know like these uh these
bump and demanded collectories like like
there are event of of sudden increase of
uh demand is a bit more likelier right
um so this spread is higher
so the main key point from this slide is
that if I give you the distribution
you're going to have you know different
way of approaching the the average value
okay
um and that's that's exactly the that's
so that's exactly the the point right if
I only give you like a deterministic
forecast so let's say if I give you uh
um this mean value right
um well you're not gonna have any
information about the noise it tells you
nothing about Thomas right we don't know
if we're in a high or a low noise uh
context
um how confident are we around the
forecast
um you know how does the confidence
evolve over time right you know do we
completely explode the confidence in two
weeks and three weeks and four weeks we
have no idea right if I simply give you
like a value it's very risky to take a
decision on you're kind of navigating uh
blindly right
um so the key main takeaway is that
point point wise forecasting right so
deterministic forecasting tells you just
nothing about noise and uncertainty and
its solution over time and given that
what we have presented about the problem
of forecasting there you know that is
basically a swimming in uncertainty well
it is natural to say that like these
methods are not necessarily adapted for
it right or they do not necessarily help
you in the exercise of capturing
uncertainty okay
so uh this is where you know we're gonna
solve the problem you can easily say
okay I can't I prefer to use the
point-wise forecasting and you know not
uh and forget about uncertainty that's
one way of seeing it but it doesn't have
to be like that right we don't have to
you know kind of drop the arms and you
know drop like drop the game we can you
know work with certainty right um uh
well this is how we can do it we can do
it with probabilistic modeling and we
can live with uncertainty it's not
fatalistic right it's not the end of the
word we can still think we can still
take decisions and and enable stochastic
Downstream applications
okay so just a reminder before we go
into this so what do we have right so
what we want from the probabilistic
modeling is uh um get the level of noise
at every forecast pointy in the future
we want to know if it's low if it's
medium or if it's high uh noise context
we want to also have the evolution of
the noise over time right how my like
how does my noise uh evolve and uh
thanks to these two components we will
then be enabled to uh
Downstream stochastic applications right
such as inventory optimizations where we
do inject some uncertainty variables
okay
um if we recap this visually so that you
know we're on the same page
um what we basically have is we have
passed let's say targets right so your
past observed values of your time series
of your demand
um we have observed inputs
um some of them are known inputs uh that
we know for the future but also for the
uh for the past one good example is
forecasted demand uh sorry is um
forecasted
weather data right so we know in the
future
um you can take these so past data that
we know future data um that we know or
not it can be continuous it can be
categorical it can be static we take all
of these we put in the model right and
ideally what we want this model to
Output is uh this year right on the top
right corner what we want is to have
Point wise forecast surrounded by their
prediction intervals right and this
prediction intervals are going to come
and help us uh in in quantifying noise
they're going to quantify the level of
uncertainty okay
so uh yeah let's drive right into it um
what type of protesting forecasting
methods we have there we basically can
split them into two big families the
first one is frequencies methods right
and the second one is biasing methods
um the the frequencies methods we can
call different ones three main big ones
come up
um first one is learning distribution
parameters learning Quantas or
confirmware predictions right
um today's presentation is going to be
mainly about the two first points so a
learning distribution parameters and
learning quantiles but I still wanted
here like to note performer predictions
because I think it's still very
interesting it's a very recent uh
methodology applied to forecasting
um but I don't want to cover it because
um I was actually pretty disappointed
when I tried to have
um let's say clean implementation of the
solution so I do consider it you know as
rather still researchy and experimental
so not yet you know um
let's say easily usable okay so I would
wanted to exit that one so so far
hopefully in the future we will have
some nice implementation that we can use
okay
so the first method that is you know
widely used and we have a lot of
libraries uh implementing it in a nice
and neat way is a learning distribution
parameters right
um what we want is for every time t for
your forecast we want to learn the
parameter of the distribution and of the
of the demands right
um so let's say we we make the
assumption that the distribution is a
gaussian one around that t then we need
to learn the parameters Nu and sigma or
if it's a poisson distribution we need
to run the parameter Lambda right
the way we do this is is by maximizing
uh log likelihood
um so that we learn the parameters data
and what we see in the industry is that
um the main method that's really employ
this and work well and can scale are
from Deep learning methods right um just
to quote you some we have Aaron and
Goshen negative binomial DPR
um yeah
um some of them allow you to have a
single shot or recursive forecasting one
recursive is DPR I think it's pretty uh
pretty uh you know known and also often
used as as Baseline
um yeah and the main point uh like the
main difficulty of this is that and it's
pretty big assumption is that you need
to make assumptions uh around the
distribution of your of your Demand
right
um that's a that's a big take
um if let's say you're forecasting
limited number of Time series in 10 or
20 and you can check you know that okay
my distribution is is is quotient for
most of them then it's fine to use that
but you know if you have
um hundreds thousands if not hundreds of
thousands of Time series right that you
want to forecast while making this
something that all of them would follow
you know like a normal distribution is a
pretty big take if they do Follow by you
know like by chance then that's
perfectly fine but otherwise I still you
know personally feel that it's a it's a
very strong take right and can be
considered as let's say a disadvantage
like in this case
all right
um the second family uh like the second
way of of of doing it is by not learning
the parameters of the of the
distribution anymore but learning
explicitly like the quantiles of the
distribution uh in question right
um and the good Advantage here is that
you don't need any more to make
assumptions about the distribution right
you don't need to assume that it's
quotient if it's following like a
t-student any or any type of decision
that you want you just learn the
quantiles of that underlying
distribution okay
um again here there are different ways
of doing it in this case it's I I'm only
presenting the explicit way of doing it
which is using what we call the pimple
loss
um where we basically compute the
pinball loss here for each of the
quantiles and then we say you know like
the sum of the pinball loss for all of
the different Quantas that we want to
measure distribution okay
um the good thing is that we have here
again many many methods that from both
ML and deep learning that allow you to
do it so it's very straightforward and
simple to do
um like the ml1 particularly are light
GBM and catboost
um they are on top of being incredibly
fast they also made you know adding this
feature very easy you just specify the
loss function as compile and you can you
know learn all the quantities that you
want
um it's incredibly you know smooth and
nice nicely done there the second method
is already a bit more complicated I
would say um it's the family of deep
learning right where you can have
multi-linear pressure prawns you have an
mq for example CNN mq as well or the
latest model there is a temporal Fusion
Transformers right
um the main point is that um you have
different methods that do this and it's
it's it like really allows you to bypass
this burden of you know assuming the
distribution right
um the second point that I want to
mention in comparison between these two
methods is that um when you're doing
when you're learning the Qantas during
the inference time it might be a bit
slower because you'll have to do like a
lot of sampling right once you have your
parameter of the distribution you have
to sample from that distribution and
that exercise can be a bit slow so often
what we see is that even if some of
these big models are are slower than the
other ones for uh
for uh during training what we what we
see is that the the if when we use the
contact lawyers for inference they tend
to be a bit quicker right so it's always
a balance to have um you know which
methods works best for you in terms of
inference or prediction time or uh
training time right it's like it's it's
dependent on every case and it's really
up to you like to Define what's the best
choice what's the best choice there okay
um and if we look at an example of you
know how the quantum forecasts work this
is from uh like the dot DS right like a
on a toy example you can see that you
know if we forecast this is what we
shouldn't have right we have the
different uh top one and and sorry so um
like the first in the 99th quantile the
10 and the 90s content right so it gives
you like this idea you can have all the
Quantas that you want but doesn't have
to be these ones okay
so yeah this is how it works
um how to evaluate right like we just
presented uh like on the like the ways
and the loss functions that you can
train the model but how can we go beyond
the last function and have some
meaningful metrics
um well they are here still two ways the
first way is let's see not the Orthodox
way it's a bit of a hack but still very
useful it's um if you want to use
pointwise metrics using the medium
prediction right let's say you use
either of the two uh previous methods
you just take the medium prediction
right and then you can use any classical
point-wise forecasting uh metrics that
you know it can be the mie the map
here like I really want to insist on the
wapi that is uh you know particularly
useful for demand forecasting
um because it basically Waits uh you
know like like
um the prediction uh like the error with
respect to the to the to the scale right
and like in demand where we might have a
lot of zeros having this weight of you
know close to zero is is very very
useful basically do not penalize values
closer to zeros in the same way that you
can have values you know are much much
higher right so this is very useful
on top of um again like if you use these
you can just take any of your uh
probabilistic methods and then you can
still compare them against let's say the
the like the classical uh methods so the
any naive Baseline forecasting methods
or the statistical ones such as arima
exponentials
the second way here is a bit you know
let's say cleaner and the recommended
way is to directly go uh and use
probabilistic forecasting specific
metrics here we can code two the first
one is the continuous track but read
this core that can be seen as a
generalization of of mie for
probabilistic forecasting or the second
one is uh cross entropy right um and the
cross entropy here I really want to
assist on this it's particularly
appreciated and an inventory
optimization and e-commerce because it
really puts a greater emphasis on on our
events right again as like as we
described it is possible that your
demand can be zero for most of the day
but then for some reason because of
discounts or festivity your demand can
really have this you know like this bump
for let's say a couple of days so this
is what we call a rare event and cross
entropy really captures the performance
on these type of data very well so uh
cross entropy and wapi are something
that you see very often on this type of
data so in e-commerce right
um so we presented like the methods like
the metrics the loss function that you
can use um and I really wanted to uh
insist on the libraries that make your
life easy and allow you like to um
Implement all of these methods and
metrics um we have a lot of them and the
list is growing uh over time so that's
that's very very good I just want to
like to code some of the biggest one
that I used and I really found very
useful we have dot TS next law there is
very new ASCII time Cleon TS and
partners forecasting my team is
personally a fan of uh partosh
broadcasting
um yeah it's really up to like like to
um to go and have a look at that most of
the methods that I just described are
are are implemented here
and yeah they make your life you know
very very easy and they are meant for
production code right not simply uh
research or experimentation but really
production code so uh feel free to have
a look I think it's um pretty
interesting there
okay and now the tree on top of the cake
and also like to conclude is how can we
you know train how can we build a
pipeline that trains and predict uh one
of these probabilistic models right so
in my team we're going to start with the
data Lake right this is this is where
all of our data sits all the demand data
all the stock data all the weather all
or all the economic indicators all of
them is it in our data Lake the first
thing is we get the features right we
concatenate uh everything together we
put our nice data frame
we put the data frame onto S3
once uh this is put on S3 then we
trigger the training and the back
testing job that uses sagemaker and GPU
clusters right um this is nice because
you can literally have several instances
with several gpus so you can really
speed up your your your training and
your back testing and once the returning
is done right you just save your model
artifacts
um in into the sagemaker model registry
or any other one that you prefer
and yeah that's the training flow
once we have the training flow the
inference flow is is again the same we
do the same features
um we put them in S3 we go and get the
model that was saved in the model
registry and then we predict you using
sagemaker batch transform with CPUs
right so there are two tricks here that
really allows us like to scale to uh
hundreds of thousands of Time series is
the first one during training is doing
like the GPU clusters this really does
accelerate right either for ML or deep
learning this really does help you it's
a bit of you know it can be a bit uh a
barrier if you're new to that but I must
say like the libraries have made it so
easy that you know most of the time you
just have to do a plug-in one example is
part of forecast forecasting that um
uses part of lightning under hood you
know just setting up a cluster of gpus
is very very easy and synchronizing that
is is you know very smooth
the second trick is doing inference
um we basically hear you by using
sagemaker batch transform we basically
parallelize the process right
um each time series become one API
request and all of our hundreds of Time
series right uh just you know go and hit
the cluster and each and does as many
requests as we want right um just to
give you an idea we have for I think 150
000 time series we can do the inference
using a temporal Fusion Transformer in
45 minutes
um yeah 45 minutes every day is you know
very very um very very quick and the
training obviously takes a bit more time
than that but the good point is that you
don't have to train your your models
every day you can turn it let's say once
a week and then you can run your
inference every day so you can kind of
you know have this benefit off of of of
balancing the speed of inference and and
the speed of training okay
so uh yeah and at the end obviously the
most important is that our forecast
going to Amazon and the stakeholders can
access it and this is the best because
they are happy and that makes me happy
so uh yeah
this was it um thanks for attending
um super useful links before we pass the
questions uh zalando including my
department is recruiting so please have
a look at the at the at the jobs thing
that I put here and you can contact me
at any point on LinkedIn if you want to
discuss or have any question or we just
want to follow up on the presentation
that I did please feel free to contact
me
um yeah that's it
hello
um hello hagop was a great session and
very insightful as well thank you very
much for that
um so we've got one question from
Milano
what are the business application what
business applications
um are you trying to solve
or the account the factuals or you want
to answer yeah so
um good question so the business
applications in my team are based to
Logistics right
um where we have basically what what I
put what I just put in the into the
slides if you if you remember
um these were the ones here right so
inventory optimization capacity planning
and also assortment planning these are
the problems that you know my department
has to solve right and the biggest ones
are these two here
um because you know having an optimal uh
event
um inventory uh replenishment policy is
crucial to having always the stock
available right so you need to have the
demand that is one input to this demand
just goes into this and then we have
obviously Downstream uh stochastic
application that does the inventory
optimization that's another modeling
process but the demand serve you know as
one of the core inputs there and the
second one is we can you know using um
demand forecasting directly we can
estimate the number of people that are
in the warehouses to process at any
given time in the next months right
um these like these two are the biggest
applications that we're trying to solve
oh um Chris thanks thanks a lot for that
um the next question is from Matt
suggestions on where to learn more on
the methodologies and all suggesting to
learn more analogies um yes I think
that's also a good question there's one
book that I always love to mention it's
the book from uh Nikola vanderput that
is a demand forecasting for Supply
Chains It's a very nice book that has
some good examples that you know is like
basically balances uh Theory and
practical sites so um yeah so let me
show you the book on the screen
on the put
and the book is yes very good books
about the country with optimization and
demand forecasting
and
let's see the book
here here you go so that's science for
supporting forecast
um yeah I think that's you know like a
very good introduction book and if you
want
um you have you know the best ways to
read the research papers try to
understand the methodologies if you want
and yeah just follow like the blog post
on how to apply this on more practical
use cases so the book the research
papers and the blog posts were how to
apply them you know very very classical